un expresidente nunca ha sido procesado
en la historia de Estados Unidos lo que
convierte la comparecencia de este
martes en un asunto único para su
audiencia Donald Trump debe dirigirse
desde su apartamento de la Torre Trump
al tribunal penal de Manhattan y se
espera que la zona esté en gran parte
cerrada de antemano con cortes de
tráfico y fuertes medidas de seguridad
Aún se desconocen los cargos exactos a
los que se enfrenta el expresidente de
76 años pero se leerán íntegramente a su
llegada él se entregará voluntariamente
siguiendo el procedimiento para acusados
de delitos penales Trump tendrá que
decir su nombre edad y profesión antes
de la clásica foto de ficha policial y
las huellas dactilares pero a diferencia
de otros acusados nos espera que sea
esposado acompañado por agentes del
servicio secreto se reunirá con el juez
Juan merchan en la sala del tribunal
donde se desvelarán formalmente sus
cargos y se le dará la oportunidad de
declararse culpable
en ese momento se le pedirá su
declaración y presumiblemente se
declarará inocente la fianza va a ser
bastante automática en este caso él no
es una amenaza para huir del país porque
se está postulando para presidente en
una serie de primarias Así que aquí solo
hay formalidades no hay una decisión
legal real
tras la comparecencia Es probable que el
expresidente quede en libertad bajo
fianza y regrese a su casa de Mara lago
Trump ha negado repetidamente haber
cometido algún delito y los analistas
legales esperan que esta batalla esté
lejos de terminar antes de las
elecciones presidenciales de 2024